Thank You crystals for these very
generous warm kind words of introduction
today we'll talk about politics now i
will talk about something different now
here is to fundamental questions you
have you want to know how fast your
school is going to get hot at a wire
tomatoes red now the first we know the
answer this very concise equation you
solve it now the other one this is the
best we know it looks quite different
now the first one is a PDE we teach this
in school then the second one is what I
call natural algorithm or an acre rhythm
because it got loops conditionals memory
so it qualifies as an algorithm and its
natural simply because we did not get to
design it he's not don't know now you
look at this some people rejoice other
are terrified because because they are
we so sure this is really going to do it
that's one question to ask another one
is are these the right variables now
this is important it took decades 19th
century to figure out that a when you
try to build a steam engine at the end
of the day there are thousands of
different parameters at the end of the
day there's only five or six that matter
you know that's the whole field of
thermodynamics and you've got to look at
the right things but then even then even
let's assume that we looked at the right
thing we had the right algorithm and
everything then what do we do with it we
just simulated what's the point where
maybe big data will save the day
actually don't believe that and look at
this maybe some of you recognize others
don't it's a chip and now you can spend
the bigger supercomputers in the world
to do big data on this you could put
electrodes everywhere put voltages
potentials just record everything make
long list and just do to do everything
possibly super computers can do you'll
never find out what it is it
computes RSA and there's a very deep
reason why one would not lead to the
other now I'd like to say be aware of
linear and not just because christmas is
here linear air was a language and
ancient Crete and we know everywhere
when I say we I don't include myself but
we know everything about it except for
wine detail we don't have a clue what it
means but except for that we know
everything and my point is that you're
going to need some kind of theory just
simply cramming data out in and out of
this won't do it and so what kind of
what kind of theory but right now
there's not so much of a choice so how
about mathematics that was working
physics maybe I'll work again so you
know Gelfond mathematician turn
biologist you know have these words to
say but the only thing more reasonable
than the effectiveness of mathematics in
physics is its ineffectiveness in
biology which didn't stop him from doing
it now of course this was in reply to a
famous quote a famous quip by bigner
badly and he admired the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics in the
Natural Sciences we have to ask why is
it so different what they actually the
answer and high level e is very simple
biology physics plus history the history
of evolution and and math has a problem
with history so what I mean is this
natural algorithm really has to be
looked at not just as a set of
differential equations as mathematics
but also as a historical document and
you know history is very difficult much
more difficult
Maddox because history may repeat itself
but you only wish certainly not quite
enough from mathematicians to make any
sense of it because mathematics is the
language of symmetry of repetition of
structure precisely what history is not
on the other hand I will make the case
but I won't have time to develop this
year that algorithms gives you the
language of memory and now let's go back
to Turing always have to go back to
touring somehow and you know you've got
the universal Turing machine you've got
the head to go the program on the left
or data on the right we all understand
this with teach this in school maybe we
want is that the distinction between
program and data is not intrinsic to
computation that's something we put in
because of our cultural biases such as
being mathematicians being engineers
being problem solvers computers solve
problems okay data we think of problem
instances and then program we think of
solvers because we like to solve things
but who says nature wants to solve
things it's not me pretty much the only
game in town in the living world is to
live that's pretty much it so in fact if
you try to come up with a principled a
principled definition of the program
it's tough okay now i'm not saying about
the famous duality between program and
data between semantics and set and
syntax that's not what I'm talking about
here I'm just saying if you're a Martian
and you land on the universal Turing
machine lucky you then how can you tell
which is the programming which is the
data well the best I can come up with is
that the program is the data that tends
not to change very
she's not a very very satisfying
definition but I cannot come up with
anything better in fact all you've got
is memory the Train wishing has no clue
buddies program what is that it just
works and all you've got is a bunch of
memory and so namely works on many time
scales in physics but and also in
biology if you look at just at the cell
rivals a little DNA very conserved part
of the DNA millions maybe billions of
years old gene expression matter of
minutes or so depending on your organism
DNA binding microseconds these are huge
time scale ratios and even the length
scales are gigantic you can easily get a
trillion length scales really we don't
get this with computers by the way so if
you think of biological organism as a
computer I think the first of all you
could have to really smooth back from
the program data the Academy where's the
program where is the data I guess what
everything is both data and program you
also have to go back and say perhaps
until I understand time scales and
length scales I'm not going to get
anywhere with this giant beasts so let's
talk about scaling 1905 since every todd
has to mention Albert Einstein so
Einstein resolved Brownian motion why is
this remarkable because after all it
sounds pretty simple a bunch of
particles bouncing around but here's the
thing at the macroscopic level this is a
deterministic process involving Newton's
laws and is intractable so this is you
know a principled way of attacking the
problem that is intractable that you can
move up a little bit to the mesoscopic
level and treat it as a stochastic
process the way we usually think about
it as a stochastic process now which
happens to be scale-free which is very
important for
in 1905 certainly because the microscope
could not actually allow you to see
those things you could only see them at
certain scales not all scales and so the
sched furnace was very important because
he met well since Cal doesn't much
matter i can pick the scale that i
prefer and of course you can remove
randomness by moving to a macroscopic
level you get deterministic diffusion it
switches all over ok so let's summarize
this is kind of interesting because you
have this upward causation from the
macroscopic which is deterministic i'm
not talking about Quentin here
deterministic reversible intractable
then you introduce randomness purely
instrumentally by the way it's purely
for the scientists sake not for physics
I then at the mesoscopic level you have
a stochastic motion and further up it's
back to deterministic you go back and
forth random deterministic just
depending on what works but the ponies
and i'm sure all physicists will
disagree with me but i still believe it
that in physics causation is mostly
upward okay we're in biology is mostly
both up and down do you have downward
causation and i can mention many example
of this well first of all should define
really what i mean by this but but
perhaps adaptiveness is is the best
example of downward causation and i was
trying to illustrate this and
I was reading The New Yorker and then I
found the illustration so here's this
work that there's a fish here just
having a grand old time no no predator
could eat the little guys in here so the
little guys adapted and so you know what
if we come together into a big fish then
that big fish will become a predator and
we downward you know the downward
causation from this emergent phenomena
down to this guy and this guy knows in
trouble has to change eat its behavior
you see I mean this is a joke but it's
also meant to convey a serious points so
what I decided to do is instead of
spending time working on flocking and
swarming if things that are done in the
past and say I want a model to study
mixed scales in particular in biology
and so I just think that a very general
model which allows me to do that which
will focus on the idea of scales and as
I came up with influence systems the
motivation was the following what if
what if you got to redesign the laws of
physics so that every particle has its
own wrong which you designed what would
happen can you say anything that would
happen now of course in in biology these
laws each block would evolve over time
but there might be very different be a
great amount of diversity so think of an
agent's we call them agents which are
pores in our d and since their agents
out
make it more visually pleasing by
putting the human beings in here and Bay
you know they live in rd and here's
what's going to happen they are going to
have a network and they're going to talk
to their friends through these arrows
and then on the basis of that they're
going to move and then they will get
another network not the same but maybe
the same not necessarily the same and
all the basis of the neighbors they will
move again in rd ok and so on this goes
on forever now how are the network's
formed how is the motion proceeding
let's talk about that so how the network
is formed I want this to be very general
because what I want to understand these
emergence when skills mix in other words
cognitively simple agents how can they
do great things simply without the power
of interaction not their own thing so I
want the network to have arbitrary power
you can have it small big it doesn't
matter so there's a function of the
agents position which determines the
network ok for example you could pick
the two nearest each agent could pick
the two nearest neighbors so typically
each agent has its own algorithm looks
at the entire world globally ok and then
decide who to talk to ok and so I'll
make it as general as possible any first
order sentence over the reels is ok so
anything will you have for all there
exists but blind in fact that the agents
could be playing games in the winner
gets to decide whether put in a July so
it's a very general it's a decidable
it's a decidable theory how do the
ageless move so that again remember they
could move in any old way but I want to
study cognitively limited ages and so
I'm going to restrict them to diffusion
which is to move so again when she moves
her next position is a function only of
her neighbors and herself
so she has her own algorithm but on the
basis of these three agents herself in
the two neighbors so that's a grand
total of 3d numbers as input she will
move and let's assume that she moves
inside the convex hull and that's called
a diffusive system and it generalizes
all diffusive system so it's probably of
all particular cases the most important
to study and also it keeps the motion
very simple for example the whole system
cannot explode cannot go off to infinity
so again each agent has its own
interaction and motion algorithm it's
like each particle has its own law of
physics okay and each one has its
algorithm what is the memory of this
each algorithm has some memory some
variables and these this memory are the
coordinates so the position of the agent
these coordinates specify the contents
of the memory okay it does not have to
be just XY in the plane or something
Kabir that's why I could be in very high
dimension could have the temperature the
pressure of concentration of this and
not okay so to specify such a system you
need n the number of agents a set of
formulas which are specified by
polynomials so you know there's this and
these are polynomial so you would
specify all the coefficients and then it
says a set of stochastic matrices to
specify how they move so just a bunch of
numbers so in fact you can look at an
influence system as a point in the space
of all influence systems the space of
diffusive influence systems and first
you can ask what can you say about this
it's a very rich theory in particular it
contains all Markov chain theory is a
very particular case but but it contains
much more than that it has three
machines for example chaos transit
tractors pretty much the whole regime of
dynamic dynamics you can have here
so okay great but I want to understand
this picture better so I show last year
that these two classes actually they're
not empty but they have measure zero ok
now the scheme is a big surprise to me
and so I won't tell you why the many
ways what this is surprising first of
all all your yappin off exponents of
these systems are are non positive now
for people in dynamics in physics this
is very surprising that you would have
chaos under such circumstances usually a
chaos means at least one positive
exponent but here that's not true ok now
let's explore furthermore how these
works this has the behavior of a smooth
analysis type of situation so let me
define what it means to perturb the
diffusive influence systems so you take
such a system and you take your formulas
and you add an epsilon here so it's a
one-dimensional perturbation of a system
ok you move it so in this way you for
any system you can move it a little bit
left and right according to some some
epsilon and I want to know what happens
over here this is going to be a very
rich structure here I mean it could be
very boring also you could just have
attractors here but it could also be
something like this so if you zoom here
so this is a bigger version you can have
a cantor set or something some fractal
structure and and all the train machines
and chaotic system will live on these on
these character sets some of measure 0
everybody it's less than measure 0 ok
it's a fractional dimension less than 10
everywhere else it's asymptotically
periodic
okay and so to understand these were
actually to prove this I had to resort
to something I'd call better serve in a
dynamic renormalization because oh you
how to analyze mixed scales so maybe
this will be more meaningful to the
physicist but if you look at the Ising
model which is good example condensed
matter physics of complex systems there
are lots of similarities with my
influence systems for one thing the
agents keep interacting and in ISIL
model let's let's take the ferromagnetic
for the simplest case you have to do
some excitation from the outside okay to
keep things going so particles keep
jiggling and that's a source of entropy
in both cases and we can formalize this
the agents want to move toward the
neighbors and the particles they really
want to jiggle like their neighbors in
sync with the neighbors that's what this
tension you have between entropy and
energy that push in different directions
now sometimes entropy wins is disorder
sometimes energy wanes and you have like
a lettuce ok but when there's a tie
sometimes not always but sometimes when
there's a tie what you get is
criticality with second order phase
transitions ok this continues phase
transitions and we're all kinds of
interesting things happen now before I
get to this there are major differences
ok influences and topology changes in
damages topology changes all the time
this is crucial whereas nursing model
topology is fixed ok you live on a
lettuce I have an infinite number of
critical points usually usually there's
a single critical point and I think
model you really study things in
equilibrium or slightly outside
equilibrium here these are completely
out of equilibrium system like
biological systems are
so to study the Ising model there's an
old technique which predates which
predates the Ising model but the
renormalization group comes from quantum
mechanics a lot it and care enough and
Wilson and people like that commitment I
mean this is one of the great triumphs
of 20th century physics and I'm so give
you a brief flavor what they do I think
for computer scientist it's a rather
natural notion you have the lattice so
you break it up into say little blocks
it's called block of and what you want
to do is coarse grain so you have a
dynamical system in here with this
interaction with the outside world you
want to simplify the inners of this
thing so we're place it back by
something that's a simpler and you do
this everywhere and then you do it again
you do the coarse graining to make
things simpler so you get a whole
hierarchy at all scales of you know
Laurie scale and so on of coarse
graining with the correspondence now at
the critical temperature something
magical is going to happen so in those
funny phase transitions you know what
you have of these are second order phase
transitions you're going to have a very
interesting phenomena like scare you
know scaling power laws and things like
that and what happened is if you look at
this coarse graining as a dynamics where
you go from one to another to another so
the dynamical system then you look at
the fixed point of that and when you get
the fixed point this is what happens
when basically all these three system
looks are the same modulo scaling modulo
scanning they are the same which is in
particular that since you know you have
interaction here at the lowest level and
you have interaction there it means that
you do have long-range correlation ok if
you disprove that if you perturb things
a little bit here there will be some
reaction over there which only happens I
criticality
is this middle oh all right okay so can
we do the same well let's try okay here
is one graph at some point it's going to
disappear okay but let's look at it well
we look for some kind of decoupling and
that's what renormalization tries to do
well here for example you notice that
these three agents operate on their own
because they don't talk to anybody else
outside and send here so you could
actually resolve these guys
independently of the rest okay oops oh
good so I will cause blame them and
replace them by bigger agents I mean
they're bigger because they're coarse
grain so there's a deal we ask more of
them and now not already the mixing of
scales that this goose is on a different
scale as these women because you're gay
I think you could you go to the picture
but if you're laughing that means you're
not getting the picture you're getting
another picture which has I don't even
know what you what your laughing about
and I'm saying this for the record so
anyway there you are well you can
continue this there's no reason to stop
so you just keep on doing this thing and
try to find decoupling elsewhere in your
things and you have some nice hierarchy
now of course this works only over some
time window because this thing is great
but but this is very important you have
no right edges because otherwise then
the decoupling is completely wrong so
there's only a time wing down where this
is going to work fine there's a time
window here from 20 then T one of those
decoupling so so you do it again and
then you do it again there's a whole
infinite sequence of such things now
this cannot work this cannot prove
asymptotic ard city and this is probably
the single most crucial difference
between classical algorithms and natural
logarithms which is that classical
algorithms the way we like to study them
is by looking at one orbit away one
input maybe a few no punitive input
worst case in put a sign but there's one
input and look and were to follow it's
what happens that's how we study but
then she cannot work you never proved
this thing goes into a limit cycle by
just following it blind him you need a
global characterization so you thought
you have to look at the entire face
space and the way it is mapped so you is
it worthless following one input you
have to look at all inputs and see how
the space of all in post is transformed
which of course is a bit more difficult
because instead of this picture now
you're going to get some kind of tensor
things like a quantum like these if you
will because now this has to represent
all possible inputs all possible
starting configuration okay so you see
you're running to a language issue I
mean
you cannot draw this but how do you talk
about it so that's why you define these
this tensor thing there's a an algorithm
called the flow tracker which will build
it and build these tensor products there
are two kinds of cancers that I get to
this in a in a little bottle but first
what you no way space space let's make
sure we're still together so you've got
n agents and each one lives in D space
so that the total of D times and numbers
okay so face bases are to the DN okay a
configuration of the system is a point
in our DM now when you look at the
algorithm that is a first look that
follow our first order sentence to
decide who talks to whom I insisted on
first order because it's a nice Theory
including people from Berkeley in here
that show that that the this theory has
a quantifier elimination which means
that in phase space you can draw an
algebraic variety a bunch of algebraic
services they cut up phase space into
rooms into cells and we need within each
cell the behavior is kind of the same
you have the same stochastic matrix so
you can even forget everything you've
heard so far justing of a large space
with this nice decomposition with
algebraic surfaces and each cell each
connected component has a stochastic
matrix okay and the dynamic now is very
clear start somewhere and apply these
stochastic matrix doing so this goes
there and then this goes there
and so on and you want to know whether
it's chaotic whether it's Turing machine
whether it's what does that's what you
want no ok nice it looks complicated but
but we have methods to do that ok so
again to follow 1.1 orbit is useless
you've got to follow if not all of phase
space at least gotta follow what happens
to a ball because this is really the
crucial object to see what happens to
our a big body in space so if you take a
ball it may or may not hit the boundary
between two so now you have to
stochastic matrices they will split up
this ball into two sub balls ok my
powerpoint skill is not that great so
anyway now you have these two others and
by luck or lack of luck they happen to
also overlap between two regions or more
than two regions it could be an
exponential number of regions coming to
a point and so you have four and then
you have a then see you can have this
explosion or maybe not or maybe yes but
so that's what you have to understand so
this gives rise to an uber essence the
sort of things now so again what I mean
to say is what you need to understand is
this I took phase space and I squished
it so you could look at it and this is T
equals zero I want to happen I want to
know what happened to the space space
when I map it to time one there's a map
all these algorithms transform phase
space and I want to know what it looks
like where there's a good way of
representing this the coding tree which
you add one dimension which is time and
then the aberrations looks like
something like this it's a tree but it's
a geometric tree it actually lives in
space as volume and so on
so again make sure you understand is the
window here to explain when you have a
point here said this is the starting
configuration it moves this corresponds
to this and then it moves again this
corresponds to that it moves again he
was supposed to that yeah yesterday my
flight was delayed a lot so I could do
that huh and see the coding tree has all
the answers I mean literally is like the
partition function of it's got
everything everything you should be able
to read of the coding 3 the problems you
don't have the cord injury do you have
it in your head but it's not you know
okay but again you can see this conflict
the same conflict you have in
statistical physics between entropy and
energy is played out here because
entropy is the branching and energy is
the thinning so to put things in plain
words if the branching is overwhelmed
the thinness see these branches are
thinned out they get thinner and thinner
if the branching overwhelms and these
are two exponential rates if the
branching over the branching overwhelms
the thinning you're going to have chaos
entropy and so forth I mean chaos Turing
machines and so on may not all of them
at once there will be a whole regime but
certainly if you have energy decays
faster than say I mean in evolution you
have something very very similar ok so
it's probably very very deep principle
to find physics and also analogy
elsewhere now the entropy is the easiest
you know many ways you can define it
what you really want to get at is what's
called the topological and should be but
but actually it's easier to just define
the entropy like this it's just
look at all the paths of length K and
take the log / k and take the limit okay
that's that's the entropy and you can
show that this is 0 almost surely and
this is some matrix rigidity Allah
valiant kind of arguments about these
matrices okay now criticality also
involves energy which is the more
interesting part ok so these branches
gets thinner and thinner you need to
understand that now thinning denotes a
loss of free energy i'll get back to the
physical the physical analogy later the
four periodicity what you would hope to
see is something getting thinner and
thinner and thinner and going to a point
like a needle if that happened you would
have always kill your dcd ok you can
prove that but unfortunately you might
get something like this some kind of
helical structure and this is because
the principle against pace can oscillate
now this is something we're not used to
when you study markov chains those guys
never oscillate but but when you do
products of of stochastic matrices you
know you have the eigenspace
corresponding to eigen value one that
space can change back and forth when the
matrices change so as a result you don't
have this kind of thinning of the branch
so you need to understand better what's
going on here and for this you need to
understand the product of suggested
matrices ok
and so for this some years back in work
that preceded days actually so for
different applications I introduce the S
energy it's a function it's a generating
function specifically aimed to
understand this this concept so take an
infinite set of stochastic matrices okay
and let G sub T denote the graph induced
by P sub T so a matrix induces a graph
by looking at other non-zero entries and
compute this function for any vector X
take pt2 p 0 times X take the ice
coordinate take the jet coordinate
raised to the power s and sum over all
edges of GT and then all times and this
might seem bizarre to you however if you
remove the outer Sun and you replace s
by 2 you get the directly form which is
a standard tooling Markov chain theory
ok so it just generalize is this but the
key is to take s not to not know L 2
norm business here ok so first of all
you can show because it's a dirty series
it's invertible it's actually a lot less
loss less encoding of the structure I
prove some bounds on these animals with
some assumptions and here's the thing
you know II of x0 is infinity because
when you think about it this just counts
the number of edges which typically is
incident because it's infinite number of
grafts so what you want to do is take s
very close to zero but not not at zero
so the idea is to pick a sneer and
derive Chernov like Belgium you know
this is used very much functional
analysis you have this extra parameter
could be a frequency could be a
temperature but we want to is s you know
what happens when you said 20 and then
you sort of
here's a picture of some of these
objects have analytic continuations not
all of them but some doing so a true one
in Mathematica and you see what happens
this is the real axis so yeah the pole
here goes to infinity and then you have
all the ink of the imaginary lines have
all these poles that repeat themselves
now here's the intuition behind this why
are we even doing this I mean I'm not
going through the algebra or anything I
don't give you a sense of why at the
basis of this there's a very simple
intuition okay and okay now look at a
stochastic matrix take a row that's a
point in our for okay so it's got four
rounds so it got four points in our four
take the convex hull of that okay so
that means that for a stochastic matrix
you can associate a polytope fine so
here's one p1 p2 another sarcastic
matrix which has another pallet of what
happens when you multiply that when you
multiply p2 by p1 you can show that wine
leaves inside the other it's like
Russian dolls you can move one inside
the other okay so when you have all
these products this is shrinking by
definition and you want to know so let's
say you study Markov chains in markov
change they're all the same so it's p p
squared p cube and so on and what you
really want to know is how fast is the
shrinking but all the standard
techniques are local they tell you how
to go from here to here and how about
shrinking there is using yep enough
exponents or spectral gaps diamond or
volume also some people have gone with
all sorts of things to study how you go
from here to here but this cannot work
okay when you have this kind of
situation because you can have long
periods where there's no progress so
instead
the S energy is a global instrument for
a given value of s it makes a statement
about the entire sequence and so that
the question is to set the right value
of s that works for you okay and so it's
a global function stop so in particular
if that's your idea of fun you can read
arrive all the classic all the classical
mixing balance for markov chain theory
but that's not the point of doing this
it's really that you can do much more
okay so let's go back to our little
thing here our flow tracker will produce
formulas like this and what do we do
with that ha here's the point so we have
yes thanks so we have our systems we
look at the set of all such we look in
phase space at the set of all possible
starting configurations we see how this
evolves we get this tree and the floor
tracker produces these monstrosities
these are little trees and it's like
you're putting trees together okay so
let me give you some intuition what does
the direct sum does it takes two of
these trees and it takes the Cartesian
product of all the paths these trees are
infinite ok so it's an infinite number
of pairs that you can form and then you
form this other one and there's a way
you induce the width of the branches and
oh
and the direct product so the direct sum
is commutative obviously because doesn't
matter when you take this is but the
drug product is not community because
what you do is you pick one guy and you
stick it at the end and then you repeat
that for all the others that's the
direct products it's not is a
noncommutative operation and the
intuition is the following you're going
to theorems that tell you what happens
to the energy of the entropy of these
trees when you add them up let's say you
have a separate lemma that tells you
what happens and you have another lemma
that tells you what happens we take the
products now when you have a formula
like this you can just parse it turn by
turn and see how these energy and
entropy grow that's the whole point so
the proof is in inherited algorithmic
because and this is the main point the
difference between renormalization in
physics which is in physics this blog
decomposition is done independently of
the physical process here the
decomposition of these graphs through
this tensor products follows the
dynamics of the graph and so it's
inherently algorithmic it's not just a
grid and just a heart here grace you
don't know what it is ahead of time
because it's produced and honestly by
its own dynamics ok so I'm I have like
five minutes or something right or three
minutes three minutes five minutes let
me just summarize the theorem difference
in diffusive different systems are so
tightly periodic almost surely they can
be chaotic or turn complete and
bi-directional systems haven't talked
about them have fixed point attractors
and we can count the number of
attractors although Bernard is not
optimal but the thing is the mixing of
timescale creates phenomenon unknown in
physic well since I'm not I'm not a
physicist for me almost anything is
unknown in physics though for me this is
probably true and maybe not for John but
where he can tell me suppose we have and
again please no stupid cracking laughing
there's nothing funny about this
business let me tell you so so let's
suppose that we have this situation here
and this trio pretty quickly settles and
so we can cause great it there we go
okay now at this point suppose that the
goose taught listens to her the goose
listens to her now what happens it means
the goose gets information about this
woman maybe your birth telephone number
whatever the goose gets information okay
now see see what happens now with
through this renormalization zone you
can show that these guys will evolve
evolve it and they will converge to a
limit cycle let's say what does it mean
to be stuck in a limit cycle it means
you've lost memory it means that you are
you have amnesia that's what it means
limit cycle means amnesia you don't know
where you come from that's the whole
point of being stuck in a periodic orbit
so everybody here is an idjit has lost
all incident and they have to they want
to be in the limit cycle but not suppose
that she decides and she can do that to
talk to the goose much later on a
different time scale remember the goose
has her information and she has lost her
memory she won't regain everything
because the goose would tell her her
name whatever she was born without her
everything so she regains her memory but
to regain your memory maybe that's
wonderful for her but this is terrible
for the limit cycle because there's
nothing mid-cycle not anymore you you
will have to lose memory again so you
see how you can amplify this and you get
this mixing of time scales this times
that can be exponential this time still
can be just a few a few steps and the
interact in major ways okay so
the views on physics or pseudo physics I
should say you can look at this as
Springs that these are one-way Springs I
know one way Springs contradicts
Newton's third law but that's a small
price to pay so they have friction
because the whole thing will is the
disabilities and how friction and the
topology changes I mean you know you can
look at mark at Markov chains as a
system with spraying said but these are
tourism and now if you only had one way
Springs with friction then this would
just be a damped coupled oscillators you
will minimize the free energy and the
whole thing would converge that's Markov
chain theory but because the topology
changes from the physics point of view
this requires the import of more energy
so there has to be an injection of free
energy from the outside the compensate
for the dissipation now this is
something that provision you know
chemist term disability structures and
he argued that basically go from physics
to to more complex things in life and so
on by using these structures I'm not
sure many by this but i'm not sure that
i buy this this is too simplistic rather
what i think is that the big challenge
for computer scientists are interested
in this and biologists and so on it is
really to find the language at some
point at this point for me it's a matter
of language not funny results
because to find these algorithms is very
very difficult to find you know which
variables to look at and so on so even
you know we'll do this later but right
now I want to know do we have analytical
tools what do we do with this thing and
I think the biggest challenge is to
capture the narrative complexity or not
to algorithms by narrative I mean that
there's a story unfolding which is
captured mathematically so that's what I
did my work on influence systems study
mix scales right now I'm a sabbatical
and working with Stan library in open
systems and adaptive structures on going
work and that's a matter
my apologies in my introduction for go
to mention that that burner is French
and these are the only folks to take
DC's
we'll thankful questions
fizik so critical phenomena are usually
there's a some kind of hierarchy of
critical points
of
used up organized yeah is there
something that abides in general you can
say yeah so yeah I saw that actually
that's what I'm working on with Stan
we're looking at spin class systems but
because what you want is large number of
metastable states and find for
topological reasons how you could go
from one to another right by using
selective in all because now now we're
mixing at you know because we don't do
physics that we just want to use this ID
to go through through us you know subtle
points that are exponentially narrow and
force the flow through that but using
natural selection kind of processes to
sort of reinforce but I boosting that
kind of thing but uh so we're looking at
this in that in that size but but I
think it's a that there has to be
topological topological structure that
makes that this facilitates the
algorithmic unfolding officer I believe
that but I don't
meaning i wish i could actually tell me
Chris Arkansas
well
thank you
you're a nuclear state land by the river
supportassist said oh me oh
No
back from that helping
we have the metrics
yeah the context of all that you hold
the view that scalability you did
mention here
would be an important construct in the
so is it
scalability what do you say like that
with respective in gtalk
I I don't think I have anything to say
so the question was about the
discrepancy method and and if it relates
to as apparently claimed two hypotheses
and ultimately if it can say something
about the complete book I mean if you
believe that NP completeness is is hard
then then it means none of these methods
can be helpful I mean up in the worst
case it means basically any sort of
algorithmic technique you can dream up
and be a waste of time so now on average
and so on because we are interested in
in worse case here we're only interested
about and even average is very loaded
term because we cannot even define
distributions but there's no
distribution that are steady state these
are constantly out of equilibrium things
so but but though I do think in this
system the mere concept of optimization
is is again probably not the best term
because optimization puts you in a
certain framework where lots of context
is frozen but organisms you know
yeah over the long term memory they
optimize things certainly but they also
do lots of other things they change
their utility function when it's time to
do so it's out
any more questions so but not listen
let's think I speak it again